welcome to my session enterprise ready
modern applications with
go the rise of digital chaos
for years one of the most talked about
topics has been digital transformation
it seems like everyone's feeling the
need to legal to modernize their legacy
enterprise applications
as technology is specialized it has
grown exponentially in complexity
two decades ago there might have been a
dozen choices that needed to be made
with typically two or three options
today the amount of choices is simply
staggering
nobody can possibly begin to understand
all that is required
three fourths of cios say managing
performance is now impossible due to the
i.t complexity
security risks have seen a similar
exponential expansion seems like every
day we hear about another major breach
the historical approach to enterprise
architecture doesn't work in the digital
age
if we don't dramatically change our
approach and soon
it will be too late
today i'm here to share with you what
the path is
we need to modernize our enterprise
applications and a lot of folks have
this wrong
they have part of the picture but
haven't grasped that true modernization
requires simplifying our approach not
simply containerizing it
who am i
i've spent the last decade and a half
leading industry changing organizations
focused on bringing simplicity to the
chaos
as senior vice president at mongodb i
led the development
of the first non-relational database to
enter mainstream use in 45 years
as chief operator docker i led the
effort to simplify containers
as a side project i created hugo the
most secure and highest performance web
engine
today i'm one of the leads of the go
team where we are building a modern
simple cloud-native programming language
since you might not be familiar with go
i'll first provide a short overview of
what go is
then i'll share with you what a modern
enterprise application requires
lastly i'll share with you how go and
google cloud will help you with
migration to modern enterprise
along the way i'll share quotes from
enterprises and how go help them
go is a modern programming language
designed by google for google's problems
of building and serving server-side
software at scale
google uses go extensively for a wide
range of things from our indexing
platform that powers google search to
the infrastructure that google cloud is
built on
launched a decade ago go has seen
explosive growth today go is a top 10
language with broad adoption among the
world's leading enterprises
go follows einstein's maxim be as simple
as possible but no simpler as go is
designed for maximum simplicity it is
very easy to learn and to work with
go drives the balance between
productivity and performance sharing the
friendliness of dynamic languages like
python and the productivity of compiled
languages like c in java
as a modern language go was designed
from the very beginning with security
and safety in mind
over the past 10 years goes developed a
large and mature ecosystem
goes loved by both developers and
employers alike ranked as the number one
language across many industry surveys
go is widely loved by developers because
it makes building modern software simple
and secure
but what does it take to build modern
enterprise applications
first of all they must minimize risk
they must be fully modern adding modern
components onto or alongside legacy
systems introduces significantly higher
risk and complexity
instead of simplifying things they
multiply the complexity you now need to
worry about many systems languages and
integration points
they must be safe modern applications
have to be built in a way that ensures
safety
according to researchers at microsoft
seventy percent of the security bugs
that the company fixes each year relate
to memory safety
google found a similar 70 of serious
bugs in chrome are memory management and
safety bugs
legacy programming languages were not
designed with safety in mind because at
the time there was no such thing as a
cyber attack and bits were at a premium
our environment today is vastly
different from the one legacy languages
were designed for
modern languages massively de-risk
applications
they must be secure
one of the largest risks systems face is
in the form of lacking security which
results in leaks and attack vectors
in the constant battle for security
applications need to utilize the latest
encryptions and protocols
they need to run in minimal environments
with maximum isolation
and minimal
external dependencies
they need to not depend on legacy
libraries and environments
modern enterprise applications must
adapt to business needs
one way they do this is by utilizing
service oriented apis
approaching applications with the
communication first focus ensures that
the application has the proper
separation
scalability and flexibility to adapt to
new business requirements
this approach also isolates each feature
for greater flexibility and security
they must be architected to be modular
and composable
techdet can be a technologist's worst
enemy this hidden tax slows down all
development
traditional inheritance-based
architectures create code that is very
tightly coupled and hard to adapt to new
requirements and very hard to maintain
which brings us to our next point they
must be easily maintainable
teams and priorities are constantly
changing we need code that is easy to
understand and pick up by a constant
influx of new engineers
we want applications that require
minimal maintenance without constant
runtime upgrades
our final theme is that modern
enterprise apps must sustain growth
they must be scalable and efficient
data and usage has been expanding
exponentially for the past five decades
with the end of moore's law and
increased pressure on computing costs
modern enterprise applications need
rapid deployment and the ability to
scale up and down with ease using
resources efficiently and keeping
operating and management costs down
they must have a cloud-native
architecture
modern enterprise applications must take
advantage of innovations in cloud
computing with a cloud-native
architecture they must be designed with
automation monitoring and repair from
the beginning favoring managed services
they must incorporate event driven
components also known as serverless
event driven features must be properly
utilized to bring cost savings
adaptability and efficiency to modern
enterprise applications
this requires software that loads
instantly with minimal resource
consumption and minimal dependencies
we're now going to go through these
requirements and highlight the ways that
go and google cloud platform will help
you build modern enterprise applications
go and gcp help you minimize risk
go is a truly modern language requiring
a completely clean implementation deep
keeping your application decoupled from
legacy libraries
well there is risk and a rewrite it
pales in comparison to the larger risk
of sticking with legacy systems or worse
maintaining both a legacy and a modern
system
goes high learnability
productivity and simplicity minimize the
rewrite risk and often pay dividends in
massively reducing both operating costs
and technical debt further minimizing
business risk
zaveod a senior principal engineer at
dropbox said
people become very productive and go
very fast our infrastructure is built
and go today and all the new things we
build and go
legacy software languages were designed
for a different era where safety wasn't
prioritized or worse often compromised
for performance
this trade-off made sense in a
pre-networked era but has created
massive risk in today's environments
modern languages like go are designed
for today's environment where safety is
critical
go is memory safe type safe and utilizes
low latency garbage collection these
features alone avoid over 70 percent of
critical bugs resulting from unsafe
legacy languages
bala a senior director of engineering at
paypal wrote in our tightly managed
environments where we run go code we
have seen a cpu reduction of around 10
percent versus c plus plus with cleaner
and more maintainable code
go has been designed to create the most
secure applications minimizing risk as
much as possible
go applications compile down to a single
binary without any local dependencies
it's not uncommon to see an application
built using only the standard library or
only couple well-vetted go dependencies
goes dependency management uses an
industry-leading tamper-evident
transparency log with built-in tooling
that ensures that your dependencies are
exactly what you expect
go as native encryption which is used to
power much of the internet including key
components of google and cloudflare
adopting go means that the next
heartbleed which impacted virtually
every application written in any other
language won't impact your application
go even supports distro distro-list
containers where there are zero local
dependencies to worry about
gcp's ci cd and artifact manager have
direct access to go's vulnerability
database and can provide you instant
warnings about security threats
finally go in gcp will help you adapt to
business needs
service oriented apis provide enhanced
agility scalability and reliability
allowing your business to adapt to
market and strategy changes quickly
go is the only language explicitly
designed to build service oriented apis
go as native support in the standard
library for all you need to build
performant and secure apis including a
high performance web server
this is go's most common use case with
over 70 percent of go developers using
go for building apis
matt a principal software engineer at
monzo shared go is a perfect language
for creating microservice architectures
the concurrency features and the
language in general has allowed the easy
creation of small and simple network
services at manzo
a unique feature of go is that its
application structure directly mirrors
the architecture of service oriented
systems
services are designed independently in a
share nothing architecture communicating
across networks
go applications are composed of share
nothing modules
communicating across channels a native
feature a native feature of go
this means that both your service and
your application composed of many
services
are using the same architectural pattern
the benefits of agility independence and
easy maintenance are twice as impactful
for go-based services
maximizing your ability to adapt to
business needs
there's an additional cognitive benefit
for developers of using a single
architectural pattern at every level of
your system
john graham [ __ ] the cto at
cloudflare
shared about go i came for the easy
concurrency i stayed for the easy
composition
kubernetes creator joe beta tweeted
kubernetes success is in part due to go
and the go community
go hits the sweet spot for distributed
system software
high maintenance costs ensure that your
technology can't properly adapt or
support business needs
go is unique among all languages as it
has been designed to minimize
maintenance costs
rapidly evolving teams are common at
google and virtually all enterprises
go's simplicity easy readability and
single binary deployment ensures that go
applications have minimal maintenance
and that it's relatively easy for
someone new to a code base to safely
maintain it
martin a software engineer at trivalgo
spoke of this hidden benefit of go
goes simplicity and its sophisticated
tooling let us scale not only our
service but more importantly the process
of software engineering itself
reducing the friction of onboarding and
training someone has a significant
impact on the company's productivity
even more so at a constantly moving
environment like travago
and benjamin kane the vice president and
principal engineer at american express
shared
after working on go most of our
developers don't want to go back to
other languages
gcp will help you sustain business
growth
historically ctos have needed to make an
impossible trade-off either choose to
delay launch as the team builds a
scalable application first
or choose to ship a slow prototype early
acknowledging that development will be
delayed significantly later as adoption
growth demands a rewrite
effectively having to choose when to be
unable to support business growth go has
eliminated this dilemma goes designed
for google scale with built-in
concurrency that takes full advantage of
today's multi-core machines and cloud
services
go enables programmers to quickly
develop applications that perform at
scale
no rewrite needed
eric a software engineering manager at
mercado libre wrote
with go the company obviated 88 of their
servers and cut cpu on the remaining
ones in half producing a tremendous cost
savings
cloud computing brings countless
benefits for flexibility and efficiency
critical to sustaining business growth
go is the only modern language that has
first class support on all cloud
platforms
go is designed for cloud native
applications
over three-fourths of the projects in
the cloud-native computing foundation
are written in go
and go is designed for container
deployment with a very small footprint
compared to the ship the world legacy
languages like java python and node
mariano a software engineer at movio
blogged
our go micro currently build in five
seconds or less
they test in one or two seconds which
includes integration tests
and they can deploy via kubernetes new
containers in 10 seconds or less
the key factor here
small images
among all cloud benefits serverless has
the largest potential for sustaining
business growth with its low cost
instant scalability and expanded
flexibility
go is an ideal fit for serverless with
broad support on all serverless
platforms
go has very low resource use and nearly
instant startup times compared to
applications written in legacy languages
that utilize
interpreters google's cloud run is the
ideal platform for go applications with
seamless deployment
go and gcp help you simplify the chaos
the biggest impediment to a company's
future success is its past success
according to dan shulman the ceo of
paypal
today's business environment is defined
by modern enterprises with the move fast
and break things culture
enterprises will need to embrace the
process of constant transformation to
remain relevant
go provides the flexibility and
performance to assist organizations with
application modernization efforts
gcp provides flexible managed services
to guide your organization into the
modern era
to learn more about go its primary use
case and to read case studies of
enterprises who have transformed their
organizations
visit go.dev
thanks for spending time with me today i
hope you've learned something i hope you
enjoyed it and i hope to see you at a
future conference or one of the many go
conferences
thank you